[Musique]
1735 Bertrand François MAE de la
bourdonnée est un personnage majeur de
l'histoire coloniale de la France dans
l'océan
indien né en 1699 à Saint-Malo il
embarque à l'âge de 10 ans comme mousse
et navigue sur les mers du globe il est
nommé capitaine de frégat bien qu'il
n'ait jamais servi dans la marine royale
c'est déjà un riche commerçant lorsqu'il
est nommé gouverneur général des
masquarges en
1735 il lance alors de vastes travaux
d'aménagement à Bourbon et à
l'île-de-fance en particulier à
Saint-Denis et à portlouis où il
s'installe il fait augmenter la
production agricole de Bourbon chargé de
nourrir de litseur et diversifie les
cultures d'exportation pour cela il
développe l'esclavage et organise la
répression du
maronnage il s'affirme aussi comme un
redoutable militaire Madras aux Anglais
en
1746 cette gloire lui vaut des jalousies
et il est arrêté avant de décéder en
1753 pourtant son administration a
durablement marqué la zone comme en
témoigent les villes de maebourg à
Maurice ou de Mae capitale des
Séchelles 1735 Bertrand François MAEt de
la bourdonnée gouverneur général des
[Musique]
mascarés I